So recall that in order to resolve the conflict, the partial order planner has
decided to promote this goal over that one. As it tries to
connect these two plans, it finds that there is an open condition problem that
we just talked about On Robot Ladder, does not match On Robot Floor. So
now it needs to select an operator whose first condition will match this state.
Robot On Floor. And those three conditions will match this state,
Robot On Ladder. And there is just one operator that matches those conditions.
And that operator is descend ladder. So now the partial order planner uses this
information to select the operator, the simulator, and now we have a complete
plan. So now you know about the algorithm for partial order planning, and
how it works in practice. But what does this tell us about intelligence?
Let's consider several postulates. First, knowledge is not just about the world.
Knowledge is also controlled knowledge. It is often tacit, but this controlled
knowledge helps us select between operators. Second, that goals provide
control knowledge. Goals can be used to decide between different operators, and
we select an operator that helps us move closer to the goal. Third,
we can view partial order planning as an interaction between several different
kinds of agents or abilities. Each agent here represents a small micro ability.
There is this agent which was responsible for generating plans for
each of the goals independently, then there was an agent responsible for
detecting conflicts between them. Then there was a third agent responsible for
resolving this conflict. So we can think of partial order
planning as emerging out of interaction between three different agents,
each one of which is capable of only a small ability. So we can think of
partial order planning as emerging out of interaction between free agents,
where each agent is capable of only one small task.
Minsky has proposed a notion of a society of mind. A society of agents inside
an intelligent agent's mind that work together to produce complex behavior,
where each agent, itself is very simple. As in this case, a simple agent for
detecting conflict, or a simple agent for resolving conflicts, and
of course an agent for making simple plans with simple goals. It is one other
lesson to take away from here. When you and I solve problems like the ladder and
the ceiling problem, we seem to address these problems almost effortlessly and
almost instantaneously. So it looks really simple. What AI does,
however, is to make the process explicit.
To write a computer program that can solve the same problem is very hard. It is
hard because the computer program must specify each operator, each precondition,
each state, each goal, every step very, very clearly and very, very precisely.
By writing this computer program is this AI agents that consults problem.
We make the process that humans might be using more explicit. We generate
hypotheses about how humans might be doing it, which is a very powerful idea.